all right
should be live now and uh I am sorry
that I am um just a couple of minutes
late I I had to drop my kiddo off
um
uh for a birthday party for a friend of
hers and I am and always have been
incredibly bad at calculating mentally
how long things will actually take so
even though it was right down the road
I still I still didn't quite uh nail the
timing on that so sorry that I kept you
waiting for a few minutes it's great to
see everybody
um Carolyn homebody hey Angus Miss
Wicked Wolf adrenaline oh Pirates happy
anniversary
that's really wonderful a Gozer Ben
this should be
this should be fun now
if you weren't here the last time I did
a live tier ranking there's a couple
things to be aware of
first is this is not going to be a deep
dive on any of the things that I rank
I'm gonna try and keep this to an hour
um I may go over that because again very
bad at calculating how long things will
take but we'll see so I'm not going to
get into deep explanations of too many
of these or at least I'm gonna try not
to so that is the first thing the second
thing is that because of how I have this
setup and the fact that I do not have
multiple monitors to work with
um I really should look into that I need
to get a bigger desk though if I'm ever
going to do that anyway sorry that's
that's a separate issue I cannot monitor
the chat while I am doing this so
um while I highly recommend and
encourage people to check if the
reactions to things to do I'm not going
to see them if you want to drop a super
chat with any specific thoughts or
questions or reactions I will be taking
a look at those at the end after I'm
pretty much done the rest of it or maybe
like a little bit before I finish I
don't know I'll decide when I'm going to
look at those but that is certainly
encouraged but that uh should get us
going
so
let me get this all pulled up and
we'll get a move on now a couple things
here uh the first is that this is uh a
so far as I'm aware pretty sure a
complete list of all of the MCU related
products it should be complete but uh
even if it is not 100 it's the template
I'm going to use now they have these
groups they're not quite in alphabetical
order but they are grouped and uh and
similarly oh and it's not even just the
MC well I guess it is the MCU because
thanks to Spider-Man no way home they
they did rope in the rainy and amazing
the Remy directed and also the Amazing
Spider-Man movie so those are here I
didn't even notice that oh God they're
all part of the Multiverse now aren't
they oh yeah those do count those do
count but anyway these are clustered
together in a weird way where it's like
grouped the franchises together but
they're also in weird orders and some
things are slightly out of order but
anyway I am gonna I am not gonna just go
down the line because then it's like
here's Ant-Man here's Ant-Man Avengers
Avengers like it's it's weird I'm just
gonna kind of move the
um cursor around land on something and
then we'll go with that so usual thing s
tier a b c d
and well we'll see how things pan out
here
um it's got to be interesting with some
of these but let's go so
dude
starting with Iron Man three ooh Iron
Man 3 is one that I have not Revisited
uh outside of having to put clips from
it for when I did the Iron Man MCU body
count so so
my somewhat faded memory of this I'm
gonna place that at a B tier it's decent
I don't have the massive issue with the
twist that some fans do uh the whole
Mandarin thing I think that's a decent
enough twist that said who the actual
villain ended up being was a bit dull it
was an interesting enough approach and
it was entertaining for what it was uh
where'd the cursor go oh oh geez uh
Marvel Legends that's just like a like a
hey here's what to learn about the I've
never watched it that's going on D by
default so the D tier is going to mean
two things it's gonna be an awesome uh
it's gonna be awesome
start to say awful and then it almost
turned into awesome but then it didn't
and switch back D is going to be both
awesome and default
um because there are a couple of things
I have not seen
so or actually I should probably just
not place it let's let's put it at the
bottom way down there on the corner so
hopefully I don't hit it again
Venom Let There Be Carnage
oh boy
what does one how does one solve a
problem like Venom
honestly
I think they're fun
I think the Venom movies are fun I think
they are stupid like they're not high
art but they are entertaining I do have
a good time with them and I had a good
time with that one it's it's not good
but boy is it fun yeah yeah that feels
like the right place
oh speaking of which there's the other
Venom we'll put them both right there
um the first one is a little bloated
compared to let there be Carnage which
is a bit more streamlined and a bit
tighter
um that having been said I do ultimately
feel they are about equal uh overall in
terms of my own entertainment and
enjoyment of them so yeah cool
oh werewolf by night
By Night hmm
[Music]
actually I'm gonna put that in the a
tier I actually the more that I think
about that the more I like it it's a
weird
um piece and like part of why I'm gonna
put it there is honestly the novelty of
it with its visual approach and its
theming and what characters it chose to
dive into just
felt kind of fresh in an era of
the Marvel films that has felt kind of
mid in a lot of ways so yeah that'll go
there the more I think about it I feel
like the B tier is going to fill up real
quick we'll see
Loki
now this will get a second season later
this year but for right now
that's that's s tier for me that is
certainly the best of the Disney plus uh
MCU shows
um and I think possibly my favorite of
the uh Disney of of the MCU shows period
because the Netflix stuff is on here
um I really like Loki a lot I mean part
of it's Tom Hiddleston he does uh
amazing work in that part but the entire
thing just had really good energy there
were a couple of small stumbling points
but for the most part it's the only one
that I have actually re-watched since it
aired and I'm actually looking forward
to a second season so yeah no it's got
to be up there
original Spider-Man I think no
Spider-Man 2 Spider-Man 2 Originals over
here Spider-Man two
that's an eight-tier movie
I'm not going to put it at S I could I
could make an argument for it at the S
tier I probably could I'm not going to
put it there though
because uh well I'll probably get into
this more when I get to the samurami
original but while it is a very good
representation of a version of Peter
Parker it's not my preferred version of
Peter Parker so I am yeah
it's it's not quite s tier honestly I
don't while I have some Nostalgia for it
I don't super love Toby Maguire in the
part
um and again he's very representative of
an era of Spider-Man that predates my
reading the comic so like he's totally
valid as an interpretation just not my
preferred one so yeah that'll go there
do
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
this one I felt a lot better about this
when it first aired and since then like
my main gripes were a bit about the
villains but the thing is a lot of the
theming hinges on how those villains are
handled and the fact that it kind of
drops the ball and wimps out on where
it's going with that does bring it down
to a b tier if I had done this closer to
when that it first come out it'd
probably be at an a tier
the the way the flag smashes are handled
though it sits worse and worse and worse
me as time goes on there are other
aspects that I think are really good the
way John Walker is handled honestly I
think is fantastic
especially his sense of entitlement
and I know some people interpreted like
him getting recruited as us agent at the
end as like a Redemption for him I never
did I read that as it is infuriating
that he's being being given in a second
chance and it's supposed to be so for me
all his stuff was really really well
done okay
Thor Ragnarok
[Music]
okay
um
all right
oh God this one's gonna drive me crazy
I'm gonna be unhappy either place I put
it it's between A and B tier and here's
the thing
a lot of what's here is great it's some
of the best Thor material
but
it's one of those things where one of
the aspects of it hits a very specific
nerve for me and something that I cannot
stand which is the Casual elimination
dismissal and or killing of characters
that feels
Thoughtless and cruel in a way that I
think is just
not fair to an audience I get
the taikawa TT didn't see the value in
the Warriors Three and was just like
let's just kill them off
I get that but
you know I cannot help but think of
someone who's like oh I really like the
swashbuckling one or some kid who was
thinking oh I like the one with the ax
who's always eating he's funny and they
are killed I don't think with a single
line of dialogue and that just it hits
me in the worst way and it I know it's I
know it's not important I know that I
know it doesn't matter I know it's not a
mate it's barely a plot point at all but
that's why it bothers me that they are
killed so casually
it really sits
so wrong with me but so much of the rest
is really good if I put it at D I feel
like I'm downgrading too much on my
personal thoughts if I put it at a I am
gonna feel a little bit gross because
what I don't like about it I really hate
um
[Music]
B B I got I I gotta I gotta go with my
gut on that and it just it just sits so
wrong and again I know it's Petty I know
this is my hang up you don't have to
share it it's mine but it
it drives me nuts anytime I try and
re-watch this movie I kinda have to jump
forward like
half an hour 45 minutes or at least skip
a chunk in the middle because I'm like I
can't I just can't all right moving on
Avengers Infinity War oh
you know what
that was s tier material
like The Avengers movies often really
felt like a proper combination of what
had come before them and particularly in
that uh phase that they came at the end
of
Infinity war was big it was bombastic it
juggled a lot of characters really
really well and it just hit
right now is it perfect no and I've seen
um some very valid arguments in regards
to how say the character of Gamora is
treated more as a prop and the
implication that her abusive Father
Figure did actually love her and that
like that is kind of gross that is kind
of gross I freely acknowledge and admit
that
and I won't defend it
but I still think it's a really good
movie and while that is a valid
criticism I do think putting the focus
mostly on Thanos for this was a very
smart move all right what do we got what
do we got what do we got
Moon Knight
that's a c
Moon Knight had some really good moments
it started out really well but it
dropped the ball really badly at the
back end where it ended in a big
climactic cgi-laden Showdown that did
not make sense for the story they were
telling at all it made no sense and it
wrapped everything up so quick and then
set up like ooh we've got other places
to go and they haven't even confirmed
that they're going to do more stuff with
this character like it's five good to
Great episodes and then one
sixth episode and that can feel like an
imbalance for me to knock it so much for
only one episode but when that episode
is the ending and it's the feeling
you're left with of what everything else
was building to ended up being you get
the Game of Thrones problem which is
even the good stuff that came before the
bit at the end where it fell apart feels
less it feels lesser because you know
that it's not building to anything worth
having so yeah I gotta put that on C all
right here we go here we go here we go
Iron Fist holy crap D oh my freaking
Lord
oh that show was so bad and somehow
somehow I watched both seasons of that
well I say somehow as if I don't know
spite I washed it out of spite
um the first season especially because
it was so bad I'm like I need to talk
about how bad this is but people are
going to tell me my opinions invalid if
I don't finish the whole thing
it was so bad it was like he's not he is
an unlikable douche in the park and I
understand there's supposed to be a
certain douchiness to Danny Rand but he
had no no likability to counteract that
at all none of that sort of inherent
charm that you need to offset the
douchey aspects like say what uh Robert
Downey Jr did with Tony Stark he had
none of the charm that was necessary to
to actually make that go down the fight
choreography which is one thing I was
really hoped for was really badly done
you could tell how much they slowed it
down because they didn't have time to
properly train a whole bunch of their
actors you could see the seams for how
many times things were done in the dark
done from angles where well that's
obviously not the actor and yet they
still slowed it down anyway to be
consistent with the times where it
clearly was the actor they teased a
dragon that they didn't even show it was
so bad
it was so bad I really really hated that
show the second season was mildly better
only insofar as it put more of an
emphasis on Colleen Wang
um and she's a hell of a lot better than
Danny is but like oh
oh good grief that that hurt that thing
hurt to watch okay let's see
oh
Doctor Strange at the in the Multiverse
of Madness that's a c
the only thing keeping it from a d if
I'm being honest is uh the flare that
Sam Remy brought it brought to it he
brought a really clear directorial touch
flare Vision whatever you want to call
it he put his own stamp on that and I
have a lot of respect on him for that
and everything that I like about it
pretty much comes down to that the story
is both super basic and super
frustrating it is the most Bare Bones by
the book narrative I think you can come
up with for a Multiverse it does not
properly take advantage of the
Multiverse we really only spend time in
one alternate universe that's just a ooh
what if one like slightly off thing but
otherwise it's a largely normal universe
and it and also what they did to Wanda
and I know I know there is precedence
for Wanda being handled the way that
this movie handles her I don't care
because I don't like it when they do it
in the comics either so that's not a
defense for me that's carrying over a
fault from the comics so yeah that that
movie's gone down in my estimation a lot
since it first came out when it first
came out it was only kind of lukewarm on
it anyways do you do what do we got what
if what if was really disappointing I'm
gonna put that at a c there were a
couple of episodes that I liked but by
and large it was not particularly
inventive and I really got frustrated
that it tried to pull an overarching
narrative by the end I'm like no what
this is supposed to be is really out
there concept and see like how how
different can this actually be but then
they start making an overarching
narrative I'm like that's this is not
what this should be at all and most of
them were
stupidly predictable I think
thinking back on it the only one I
really really liked was the one where
t'challa became Star-Lord
I think that was the only one that I was
like see this is the kind of complete
reshaping of the Universe I am here for
and the rest of them just did very
little for me like I got some
entertainment out of the Thor one just
because it was kind of goofy and lent
into the comedy of it but by and large I
can't even remember a big chunk of how
those even went half the time it was
very unmemorable that was a real
disappointment
uh let's see
ah end game end game is s tier end game
was such a good wrap-up of what the MCU
had been up to that point and honestly
anyone who chose to stop watching the
MCU there and treat that as a proper
ending to the whole thing valid
it works as that I kind of feel about it
the same way that I feel about
um X-Men Days of Future Past which is
that
it
does allow for more stories to be told
but it really works as a as a closing
off point and I appreciate that it does
because as much as you know the thing
has gone on since then
I really do appreciate having some
points that'd be like if you want an
ending here's an ending
because the sense of there's more
there's more that you overplay that and
just feels like nothing ever ends and
nothing's ever satisfying that had a
really satisfying conclusion feel to it
and I'm and I like that it did
uh and again like for all the stuff that
it had to do all the balancing acts and
all the characters and
that movie's really good and it's it's
really triumphant by the end it's it's
so good all right what do we got Ms
Marvel oh
this is
well this is gonna be all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna nudge it up to a B I was
debating a c
but I think
if I were if I were to compare it to the
other
um Disney Plus show that I've that I do
have at the CTR Moon Knight Ms Marvel
did leave me going I want
to see more of this Moon Knight left me
going I'm not sure I want to see more
than this because I don't know if you
know what you're doing
um because they had a really good thing
and then ended it in a way that like
told me you didn't understand the appeal
of your own thing Miss Marvel
understands what its appeal is
the structure of the of the show as a
whole is a mess it is doing two seasons
worth of stuff in one and it's
it's again it's frustrating it's
frustrating disappointing given how much
I like that character and I want to see
her get the best shot but
it it did let me down but the stuff that
is good in it primarily the cast uh that
is in it does bring it up to the beat
here all right what do we got
Guardians of the Galaxy the first one
it's a it's a solid B
I I appreciate it sort of more for
signaling to the MCU it's okay to be
weird it's okay to at least try and
start to be more colorful because things
were kind of entering into a sort of
grayed out color palette around that
point and actually Guardians of the
Galaxy has that a little but it was a
film that obviously would have benefited
from a brighter color palette and I feel
like the mood and the tone
helped move Marvel into that later on
it's it's a good solid cast it's a good
ensemble
I don't feel a ton of attachment to it
outside of like yeah I'm this is the
kind of thing that I'm very happy to see
within this universe it's good it's a
fun time
all right what do we got Captain America
the First Avenger
hmm
[Music]
um
you know this is this one's going to be
controversial that's a c
that's a c movie
Chris Evans is fantastic in it he is
absolutely spot on damn near perfect
as Captain America himself
however
a lot of what's going on around him I'm
sorry it just doesn't work
it was uh an intelligent move to to
structure it the way they did and like
have it be a period thing have it have
the feel that I mean getting the
director of The Rocketeer was a good
call but Tommy Lee Jones is asleep in
this movie both Bucky and uh Peggy
Carter are well cast but don't get all
that much to do the Red Skull looks
great but is never threatening a huge
huge damning part of this movie for me
is how Hydra is handled and that's on
two fronts one they immediately
basically split them off from the Nazis
and be like they're even worse than the
not no just have them be the Nazis
that that's part of why they're awful is
they carry forward that ideology don't
try and be oh they're even worse no that
was so stupid and then there's the fact
that
at no point does it feel like Hydra is
winning the entire movie they are being
beaten back thwarted it feels like
something like the GI Joe cartoon
it's like is Cobra really a threat when
the good guys literally always win
pretty much every time like maybe with
one casualty here and there but they
always win how threatening are these
people Hydra feels that way and like the
big the big scary threat is oh they have
advanced weapons it's just a ray gun
and you know what they're being gunned
down by normal troops carrying
old-fashioned guns with bullets just
fine
like the threat the the weakness of the
of the villains and the not proper use
of some of the supporting casts really
did bring it down for me Chris Evans
shines but like the rest of it I really
I disengage from that movie so much
let's see
One Division oh
for similar reasons to Moon Knight
that's going in the C tier it starts out
so intriguing and its format so
interesting and then it goes
like it ends in a wizard fight in the
sky which is
in no way
the appropriate thematic ending for that
story
in any way shape or form
and like Agatha look I love Catherine
Han she's a wonderful actress a great
presence I hope the spinoff show they're
doing with her is great but
that character has no business being in
this story none absolutely none
whatsoever and her appearance and the
fact that they could have the brilliant
idea of casting Evan Peters as fake
Pietro but then do literally nothing
with that idea beyond the pop of the
reveal
by the end it was so much squander
potential and it started out so
interestingly that it has the same
problem as Moon Knight like you had
something but I don't think you even
knew what was good about your own
product because how you chose to end it
to me says you didn't understand like
this was a big part of what was so great
about Loki yes there is a fight towards
the end but it's not with the big the
big villain just shows up in the final
episode and just talks
and on paper that's terrible but in
practice I loved it I was mesmerized by
it I was so relieved it was not like a
big a big fight it was a philosophical
divide it was a it was a philosophical
question of what do we do in this
situation which is what that ending
should have been and it's what the
ending to something like Moon Knight or
one division should have been but wasn't
anyways let's see
Captain Marvel
you know what that's an a-tier movie
that's one that's grown on me uh because
I have rewatched it and it is it
part of its Nostalgia I will grant it is
evocative of the 90s not just for being
set there but just in its approach to
storytelling so like I'm a little bit of
a mark for that I will grant but I think
the performances are good I love I love
that the ending confrontation is Jude
Law's character being all like face me
without your powers and she just blasts
him into a rock it's like no
oh I'm not following your rules
good awesome fantastic appropriate
thematic ending for I think a really fun
pretty strong movie overall I know that
a lot of the initial backlash was BS but
I feel like it hasn't gotten the proper
reassessment that it deserves following
all of that
so moving on from there
Captain America the Winter Soldier
that is an eight-tier movie that was a
big step up from First Avenger in terms
of like really leaping forward into a
completely different genre and bringing
that sense of political Intrigue and
bringing in someone like Robert Redford
but that was beautiful but having cap on
the back foot giving that philosophical
divide between him and fury and then
even a further divide between Fury and
the other people heading up Shield
I really like how that was approached I
like the focus on Bucky and uh Steve's
relationship I like that we didn't get
full resolution on that but it still
felt like it ended at a climactic moment
that was a good point to end for that
movie even though there was more places
to go later it's just really well put
together I get why the Russo brothers
were kind of given the Reigns of the
bigger projects after they put that
together because it's really good
let's see Iron Man 2 it's C it's
forgettable as hell that movie there is
so little worth remembering there's like
the image of Tony in the donut
uh there's the introduction of Black
Widow and
uh
like it doesn't leave a horrible
impression but it leaves almost no
impression whatsoever
not even gonna say anything more about
that do you do what do we got Ant-Man
the first Ant-Man
ah B that's a b tier movie it's fun it's
a good time
um I liked some of the comedy vibe there
was some inventiveness to some of the
action scenes
um given how where the franchise has
gone later I really feel a lot of that
is lingering influence from
uh directors who did not stick with the
project initially Edgar Wright and then
uh Adam McKay who both dropped out and
uh I feel like their influences lingered
enough to contribute to some of the
better stuff in that movie but overall
like it's it's fun it's fine it feels
like a palette cleanser that one
Spider Man Three
whoo boy
um
oh
okay
I know this has gotten a critical
reassessment in some circles
I still really think it's trash I really
really do I I it's one of those ones
like like Batman and Robin where I think
to myself okay it can't possibly be as
bad as his reputation it can't possibly
be as bad as you know my memory of it
and then I try and re-watch and I'm like
no this is really really bad and a lot
of people rag on the Venom aspect and
the black suit because Randy didn't want
to include those honestly I think that's
some of the stronger stuff I think the
Sandman stuff is way worse way worse
than Venom the fact they had to retcon
Uncle Ben's death to make this the real
killer of Uncle Ben just because that
was the only way they could think to
motivate Peter to give a damn
that like that alone should signal how
weak the entire concept was and Sandman
was the character that was always going
to be used so like that to me says even
without the insertion of Venom in the
black suit this was never going to be
good so I'm sure it didn't help that
Remy neither liked nor got Venom or
Venom's appeal but like even everything
else going on around that it's not good
it's not
okay let's see
the Defenders
uh d
that started out
real promising it started out good it's
it started out being real fun watching
Luke Cage and Daredevil and Jessica
Jones you know be together and meet and
I mean Danny Rand was there too but he
actually wasn't bringing things down
nearly as much people were calling him
out on his BS and he had pretty good
chemistry with Luke Cage which he needs
or would have needed if they had
actually moved forward with the standard
pairing of those two together which they
never did uh after this but like the
second half just falls apart so bad and
it hinges
so much on the hand
and on the Netflix version of Elektra
who I think is a boring character who
had zero chemistry with Daredevil and
the hand is one of these stupidest and
worst handled ideas in the entire MCU
they barely make sense they are not
really threatening as a presence what
the what they are actually
um dangerous for other than like oh some
of them are ninjas like okay
like why why shouldn't a reason to care
about the hand is never given so much
stuff is unexplained they ditch a really
good villain in Sigourney Weaver's
character with several episodes to go so
that Elektra could take over and just
make me not care about any of it it
didn't start out terrible but it was bad
in the entire second half yeah
all right black panther oh
uh
that's an S tier that's an S tier movie
that was a debate between A and S for me
it is really good now
while I really do appreciate what they
do with killmonger in this I don't like
that it's kind of become
um or at least is starting a pattern it
might might become a bit of a template
for how to handle villains with a point
um because they kind of recycled that
um that aspect with the flag Smashers in
Falcon the Winter Soldier and it worked
way worse there like way way worse I do
think it does work in Black Panther the
you know the villain with a point who is
taking things too far like it's a it's
something I don't want to see the MCU
keep doing
especially given that the villains with
a point have points about very real
world problems
but then are also forcibly put down and
killed like it's an issue but I do still
have to say that it's really well
handled and the performances are
fantastic and the vibrancy of it the
sense of a world and how just fully
formed everything is in that it's really
really really excellent stuff
okay
Luke Cage
it's it's going in the seat here it
like
three quarters of the Netflix shows
really really good casting on the lead
character
and even some really good parts
but it never quite pulls together I'd
say the best uh if you want to see the
best of what the Luke Cage show was
watch the first half of season one
that's quite good
but then like they would repeat in the
Defenders they kill the interesting
villain we've been invested in to bring
in another villain that is supposed to
be worse but we have no reason to
freaking care about
so and then I honestly do not even
remember a lot about the second season I
remember liking the way the second
season ended in so far as it made me
really excited to see what they do in a
third season but we never got that
so
I cannot
I cannot remember
whether the second season some aspects
of the second season were actually quite
good I remember some of the character
Dynamics and some of the relationships
but like a lot of the specifics it's
it's all faded in my head
Misty Knight was a real good addition
though she was a real good addition in
season two
anyways
Doctor Strange the first one
we're gonna put that at a
um I feel like the second film really
failed to bring it up to a new level but
there is an inventiveness to that first
one that I still really appreciate right
down to how the villain is defeated by
not just beating the crap out of him I
love that resolution I like the journey
for strange as a character I love Wong
the main villain we actually deal with
keikelius is a bit mad meckelson Brayton
has enough presence to like have him
still kind of work but you know there
isn't much there but there is enough I I
feel like it's possibly
one it's one of the better if not the
best origin story movies that the MCU
did
it's it's really well done you can tell
they've really refined the the format at
that point and it's it's quite good I do
yeah I still like that one a lot
where did I land ah Captain America
Civil War that's a that is a tier again
for everything that it has to balance
the number of characters the size and
scope of the threat but also never
losing sight of the heart of the
conflict the irreversible divide between
cap and Tony
it never loses sight of that and it has
a villain it has Zemo but defeating Zemo
isn't the point
and Zemo kind of wins he gets what he
wants he sees this Team rip itself apart
it's difficult to end on a note that is
not happy like the Divide is there the
terror between them might be irreparable
to have it end on that and still have
you come away from the movie going yeah
and have that feel satisfying that's
hard
and that movie does it it's it's good
all right where am I Amazing Spider-Man
cool
this Ah that's a c movie it's just kind
of there it's fine Andrew Garfield is
charming and the part actually a lot of
the cast is charming uh in their parts
but like there's
very little to distinguish it otherwise
it's too dark visually and washed out it
doesn't really seem to get the appeal of
its own character all that much
it really doesn't get that Peter is just
supposed to be a normal person that
something amazing happened to and they
instead create this weird sort of
Destiny situation but like I think the
charm of the cast keeps it off the
bottom
uh Ant-Man and Quantum Mania
oh
um
see this is between B and C
like I did enjoy it I did I had fun
but
I have to admit that there isn't really
much that I ever need to go back to I'm
going to give that a c I feel like if I
ever re-watch it it's mainly just going
to be to see Jonathan Majors again and
the rest of it is fine I don't actually
think very much of it is bad it's just
not enough of it is good uh to bring it
up like the performances are fine for
the most part Jonathan Majors is a big
draw for me in this and like there isn't
really very much that I'm like oh that's
bad and I include Modoc in that but
there isn't really much that's that's
good so it's not
uh it's not a Confluence of bad things
it's a lack of good things that's going
to put it there yeah
Avengers the first one
yeah that's gotta go a tier like we we
need to remember the impact when that
thing came out how massive a splash that
was how unprecedented that was in modern
filmmaking to even try and do and the
fact that it does it so well that it
pulls all these characters together and
it it gives a threat that feels
appropriate while also by bringing Loki
giving a certain sense of familiarity
watching the characters bounce off each
other it's
it's still really good it's still really
good and like I say that as someone who
isn't really all that comfortable
praising Joss Whedon anymore but like
the movie's still damn good it is it
just is okay
The Incredible Hulk uh
see
uh mainly for forgettability like I kind
of remember it largely as a oh right
that happened didn't it and a bit like
Ant-Man quantumania I don't think
there's really that much that's wrong
with it
there just isn't that much that makes me
go yeah I should check that out again
about it and I've rewatched most of it
um trying to get back to the MCU body
count which I will wanna I will
eventually but like they're a ton of
work
um I will eventually get back to the MCU
body count because Hulk's the one I I'm
in the middle of trying to work on so I
have re-watched it pretty much and it's
it there's nothing wrong with it but
again a bit like quantumania like there
isn't a lot that elevates it either
which is a bummer
oh
okay what do you got the Punisher her
ah
see I'm debating not putting it on at
all because I didn't see a lot of it
um I'm gonna put it at C because that's
where a lot of the kind of boring stuff
is going because that's the thing I I
know it I think it did I think he got a
second season
I didn't watch that I didn't even finish
the first season I got halfway through
and I was bored
like I got through Iron Fist riding on
spite because spite is energizing
boredom is not I was bored I don't
particularly like this iteration of the
Punisher I'm not gonna say it doesn't
work in any setting we'll get to the one
where he does but I really did not find
anything interesting about telling his
story
um you know with just him
so yeah I'm gonna put it on C because
like I was just bored
it just was
all right
uh oh Guardians of the Galaxy Christmas
special
uh that's gonna go on C and that is one
that like I said mostly nice things when
I reviewed it because like yeah no that
was fun but it sort of in an inverse to
werewolf by night like the more I
thought about the more I'm like oh that
was kind of a big old nothing
it's not awful but it's like
I definitely never need to see that
again so yeah yeah that's gonna go there
Avengers Age of Ultron
that's a b it's got some good it's
actually got some really excellent
individual scenes and James Spader's
Ultron as a villain is great
but it doesn't pull together it's
something that's actually less than the
sum of its parts because almost all the
individual elements I can praise all day
long but the way that they're assembled
and pulled together just doesn't quite
fit it doesn't build into a cohesive
whole the way that I it needed to the
way that the first one did so yeah it's
it's a it's a BJ it's fun I can still
enjoy it and there are aspects that I
quite like but it it just isn't quite
there without one
uh Ant-Man and The Wasp that's a c
I like I was just again I was bored and
the structure on that is a mess
like there's so many characters and
factions and groups involved and like
why
why why is the FBI
such a major focus in this what is the
deal with freaking
I can't even remember the character's
name the guy who the guy who wants the
the lab for himself I'll tell you why
it's reverse engineered because they
needed goons for the heroes to beat up
and they weren't going to have them beat
up the FBI because it would be
interpreted as well these are just law
enforcement doing their job you can't
beat the crap out of them fine we'll
come up with a contrived reason for this
guy to just throw a ton of goons to the
point that like there's literally zero
connection between the mountain of goons
our heroes are fighting and the eventual
main villain of ghost who is severely
underdeveloped and barely works and
there's a serious misuse of or underused
rather of Michelle Pfeiffer and Lawrence
Fishburne there's still a charm to it
largely brought by the performers even
the ones who are underused and that's
what's keeping it off the D tier but
like
yeah
oh and Michael Pena
he he keeps that off the detail the D
tier
um
[Music]
this
it's a b it's a strong B it's almost an
a
it's almost an a
but like a lot of the movies in the last
few years
it has the wrong ending it has the wrong
final confrontation because it has the
final confrontation it should have
between Sean Chi and his dad which is
where all the emotional core of this is
and then the movie goes on for another
10 minutes with a big CGI battle between
a monster and a dragon and like it's
visually impressive but I don't care
because the emotional heart of the
narrative is already been resolved and
dealt with so why are we still going
and that
that to recognize what story you're
actually telling and to end it
appropriately at the appropriate point
which is a problem that plagued One
Division and it was a problem that uh
plagued got what else
um there was something else I said about
Moon Knight and that that is a problem
that I might even be knocking the movie
more than it deserves for this
uh I feel like I'm dragging it down more
than it deserves it is a because up
until that point here's the thing
here's okay here's why I just moved it
up to a I stand by everything I just
said but
it doesn't have the wrong final
confrontation instead of the correct one
because that's what happened with one
division with Moon Knight
and those just have the wrong final
confrontation the wrong climax shanxi
does have the correct climax
it just then also has another one on top
of that so I'm gonna I'm I'm okay
shifting it up to a because it's not
lacking the right ending it just doesn't
end on it so that is that is ultimately
less of a sin than just flat out having
the wrong climax which is what some of
the others had
I feel good about that uh
wakanda forever
this one is tough
this one is between
A and B for me
there's a lot of good stuff there's some
fantastic performances in this
especially and it's really interesting
as a piece of art that stands as an act
of mourning
that you you get that this was made as a
in honor of the death of Chadwick
Boseman
that having been said while I do like no
more as a character having him be the
main villain feels off in some ways and
also some of the specific decisions like
I don't think it was necessary or even
wise to actually kill off uh the queen
um
I am gonna slot in the a tier I feel
like I need to I need to sit and
ruminate on it a little bit more I'm
gonna give it the benefit of the doubt
today though
uh what is a Spider-Man no way home
no way home no way home no way home
um
[Music]
that's a it's one of those things that
like it hits the Nostalgia so hard
pardon me goes like are you Nostalgia
blinded to a movie that doesn't deserve
as much praise as you give it and like
Maybe
but if it works it works and it worked I
mean that's it I don't even have much
more to say beyond that
where did I end up Thor the original
Thor
it's not that good
it's not that good I've gone back and
tried to revisit it and Hemsworth's
performance is solid he's definitely
well cast but he's he's not quite
settled into the role yet it feels a bit
more put on
um edelson's Loki is good right off the
bat I mean like the cast is good but it
feels just a little bit artificial not
just in the visual presentation but in
the way the characters behave it feels
like everyone's kind of just starting to
get a handle on who it is they're
playing and it's not quite there yet
it's an excellent Foundation to do good
stuff with later it's not that much on
its own though
Daredevil oh crap
this one's really hard to know what to
do with
because it's very uneven season to
season
because season one
is great
excellent even
season two the first half of it
is pretty good
it's not
uh excellent but it is definitely the
best use of the Punisher that the
Netflix shows did
the second half of season two though
which goes into Elektra again they have
no chemistry at all and that is a big
problem season three felt like a pretty
satisfying conclusion at the time
although I struggled to remember a ton
of the specifics beyond the final
confrontation with the Kingpin so I
don't know how well it stuck with me so
I'm
it's very uneven where do I put uneven
we put on even in the B tier that's
where we put uneven
which one Iron Man original Iron Man
even as I place this I'm gonna say I
understand I'm kind of
giving it credit for kicking the whole
thing off maybe even more than it
deserves taken as a movie unto itself
but I'm gonna put it in the eight here
it really does do everything it needed
to do right it does right and everything
could have gone wrong right off the bat
but it doesn't and I think that movie
still deserves all the credit in the
world for that
Hawkeye Hawkeyes
Hawkeye's actually quite a good time
Hawkeye
is actually an a tier show
it's not the best of the Disney Plus
shows you know we got Loki right up
there at the top but Hawkeye
Hawkeye was good stuff the um the
dynamic between uh the two leads was
excellent it it really did so much
hinges on it Echo was a fantastic
villain well explored while I feel like
they didn't quite use him as well as I
would have liked the presence of the
Kingpin at the end actually worked
it works as a solid sign-off for uh
Clint Barton if they don't decide to
bring him back and yeah
good time oh and Yelena Elena was so
good in that yeah yeah I'm comfortable
there all right what's next
Spider-Man far from home that's a c
that really just
there's very little that left me with
too many good feelings about that
that one's a case uh again of really not
that many stuff not that much stuff
that's terrible
but just boy
not a lot that is good
there's very little that I can point to
that makes me go well there is that and
there isn't really that much that makes
me go oh that was a terrible idea but it
just
it just left me numb I was like okay
that was a thing it made me really
nervous for the Tom Holland movies going
forward thankfully they got good again
but yeah all right what's left the
original Sam Raimi Spider-Man that is a
b movie it was revelatory when it came
out
but it was um
it was as I said not my preferred
version of Spider-Man
and it just it was informed by the 60s
and the 70s
eras of the um of the comic and that's
that's that's just not my Spidey it's
still good
um well in the foe is great in it and
you know the character Dynamics are good
Uncle Ben is fantastic like there's
still a lot of real good stuff there but
it I just never loved it as much as a
lot of other people did
okay what's left
Amazing Spider-Man 2.
is gonna go on C tier along with the
first Amazing Spider-Man a lot of people
consider this a significantly worse
movie I don't it's not a good movie but
the strengths are the same strengths
Charming portrayals on the characters
um
and Visually it's but it's got I think
probably the single best suit of any of
them and I include the Tom Holland one
like the suit is amazing it looks
fantastic and while the handling of Gwen
Stacy's death was really well it was
also unearned so that feels like a wash
um and I actually really really like the
ending I really really like the ending
where it's just him putting the mask
back on and going to take on the Rhino
and it just cuts to Black it's like yeah
we know how this goes the point isn't
how does that fight go the point is he
put the mask back on and got back in the
saddle and that's the point they need to
be I actually really really with the
ending note
the strongest part of the movie I think
but yeah no it's not great
what is left
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2 a
it just it understands the emotional
core or I guess more accurately the
emotional damage
of the characters
so well and it does a really good job of
mining that for good strong storytelling
and really digging into these people
it's it's really that is a movie that
has gotten better with age and with
additional viewings
what's left the eternals
um I am more positive on that than a lot
of people were
but
I don't ever need to see it again
um
it's a c it's a strong C it is close to
a b
but it's not it's just not quite there
it's it's got a lot more strength than
people give it credit for
I think I think it dropped the ball with
uh some of its villain choices some of
its overall narrative structures a
little wonky it and the strengths are
there but they're not as strong as they
need to be to to make me want to revisit
it I'd be up for seeing more of these
characters and see more done with them
but yeah
when I don't ever need to see it again
and I'm like if someone would ask me hey
you want to re-watch this Marvel movie
and my gut reaction would be is there
another one you'd rather re-watch it
probably doesn't belong any higher than
a c
okay I feel like I can just go down the
line at this point
Spider-Man homecoming
that one's real good that is that is an
a-tier movie that is
close that one's real close to being an
S tier it's oh it's right up there it's
right up there I love the villain I love
Tom Holland in the bar and I understand
I did not want another teenage
Spider-Man after Sam Raimie Spider-Man
and The Amazing Spider-Man like don't do
teenage Spider-Man again and they did
but they still made me love him
I love this iteration of Aunt May I love
that it's a smaller scale conflict I
love the vulture I think this is really
well done I think MJ is an interesting
Twist on the character it's just really
actually you know what you know what
it's an S tier that is an S tier movie
I'm starting to think like what is I was
starting to think what is it that keeps
it out of being yes here and I'm like
nothing nothing keeps it out of being
asked here s tier there we go
sometimes I have to talk this stuff out
to really settle on it Thor the Dark
World
that's a d
it's just so Bland
it's visually Bland it's narratively
bland
it's it is so forgettable it is a movie
I literally frequently forget exists if
it wasn't for the fact that I'm like all
right christak and Christopher Eccleston
was in this I wouldn't remember at all
and unfortunately for Christopher
reichelson it's not because he was a
super memorable memorable villain not
his fault but it's because I'm like oh
right it's almost like a piece of trivia
oh that's right but
Black Widow
it's a b
like I love Elena she is a big part of
this and the the family Dynamics between
the characters uh it does a fair bit to
bring it up but the overall
um
um just the overall feel and uh uh
having it be the final note for Black
Widow like I'm glad she finally got her
own movie but it's like it's solid it's
solid it's good I'd give it another
watch but
man
it's okay it didn't jump out it's but
it's good it's not great but it's good
Thor love and Thunder
hmm
[Music]
all right let's
put that in the B tier I like it a lot
more than a lot of people like it a lot
of people really hate it I actually find
it to be a lot of fun
I will grant that it's very popcorny
it's pretty disposable it is arguably a
bit of a waste of the concept of Jane
Foster wielding mjolnir it doesn't do as
much with that as could have been done
but everybody just seems to be having so
much fun they're having so much fun
being there I think the villain was
pretty well handled I love the kids
getting empowered for the climax I love
I love that to death I remember hearing
so many bad things about this and then
going to see it in the theater and
sitting there thinking
when does it get bad
because I'm having fun with this
I I debated putting this in the a tier
the thing is while it is fun
it's got a lot of good stuff
stuff
and good not great
that feels like B tier
assessment to me
Jessica Jones
ugh
so Jessica Jones is another one that
I have not seen every season
I saw the first season which is
incredible it's like it's like maybe an
episode or too too long but it's
incredible
the second season
just didn't know what it was doing
and I started to watch the third season
and realized I think Karen didn't finish
it so that makes it uneven with a super
solid start which makes it of the same
caliber as the Daredevil show even
though I think it has the better for
season than Daredevil season one but
that's gonna put in the beat here uneven
uneven stuff goes in the beat here
we're almost done because I am Groot I
have not seen so that stays off the list
so
She-Hulk
it's a bee
but it's a weak B
it's
it pulled it together at the end the
last three episodes
are basically exactly what I wanted the
rest of the show to be and it failed to
be and a lot of what the rest of the
show was
bugged the heck out of me really drove
me up the wall because I love She-Hulk I
love She-Hulk and in specific I love the
runs that this is pulling the most from
and yet it didn't work for so long but
the fact that those last three episodes
are as good as they are and the fact
that it ends so well like I've talked
more than a few about these especially
the shows where they started out
promising and fell apart
I need to give it credit as rough as the
front end of it was I need to give it
the credit it deserves for pulling it
together in the back end because if
you're going to do anything strong
finishing strong
that yeah that cat that has to count for
something
because starting week in finishing
strong will always be preferable to
starting strong and falling apart it
would be better if the whole thing could
be strong but I gotta put it there and
that leaves us with
morbius uh you know
when I watched that movie
I had wanted it
I'd wanted to have an experience similar
to the Venom movies where like this is
not good but it's locky fun and I'm here
for it
it couldn't even manage that
Matt Smith was the only person in that
entire movie who appreciated what it was
he was in he was the only thing worth
watching it's a d
and Matt Smith is great in that movie do
not get me wrong the character of Milo
is excellent and you will never convince
me that it was not Matt Smith's
intention that every single line he
delivers to Michael morbius is dripping
with lustful homosexual subtext you will
never convince me that was not his
intent with the delivery of those lines
it's not enough though everything else
like I can't recommend even though he's
the best thing about it I can't
recommend sitting through the rest of
the movie just for him because it's a
visual disaster it is a slog and most of
the characters are boring and half the
actors seem asleep
it uh that really was uh that was a mess
and not as much of a fun mess
as I had hoped
well that takes care of that
all right looks like we got one super
chat in while I was doing on that thank
you very much John vinyls MCU Thanos is
a really good portrayal of a narcissist
who's convinced he's right he doesn't
see how much he's a privileged jerk wad
wrapped up as a self-justification I
agree it is actually one of the things
that really bugged me you know when
people be like what it's so stupid if
Thanos can do anything why is he getting
rid of half the universe why doesn't he
just make more resources because he
doesn't think that way because he's not
an altruist like you said he's a
narcissist more than that he's a sadist
he's a sadistic narcissist who claims
he's trying to save the universe and
maybe even believes that he is but he
will not consider the altruistic option
because that's not how his brain works
it's not a fault of the storytelling
it's revealing of who he is as a person
so yeah absolutely
a movie so bad at bomb twice oh morbius
yes
I love
I love that they re-released it
they re-released it to theaters because
it was meme to hell and they thought
like oh well people will see it now and
no
no they won't
because nobody was memeing it because
they enjoyed it they beeped it because
it was so bad
hahaha
ah all right well I think that is gonna
wrap us up oh I only went 10 minutes
over my intended run time that's not too
bad that's not too bad at all
so I hope people had fun I enjoy doing
these kinds of things now and then again
it's not going to become the regular
thing but as a as an occasional yeah
it's fun no rank for Deadpool Deadpool
has not I understand why it's not on
there because Deadpool has not yet
been pulled into the MCU and we don't
yet know if they're going to explicitly
tie him into the Multiverse or if he's
just gonna stand as his own thing
there's some stuff that is
there's some stuff we're learning that
is implying they're somehow going to tie
it into the Multiverse which I don't
love because I don't think you need to
justify Deadpool just do Deadpool he
shouldn't make sense you shouldn't have
to explain him but
um I'm I suspect that a tear like this
once Deadpool comes out especially if it
gets tied into the Multiverse
that this tier is going to become way
way bigger because like how they had
they had all the Spider-Man movies here
because the Multiverse confirmed that
they're all tied together they would
have to do the same with all the X-Men
stuff which would make this whole thing
a much much bigger project
I want Moon Knight to be a standalone
thing I worry that the did
representation is going to fall by the
wayside if they try to connect it to
anything that's distinctly possible
knowing humans though yeah you're right
oh also
it isn't on there
I wonder if
because
the MCU Kevin feige and others have been
really squirrely about confirming either
of those like in theory Agents of Shield
should be tied into it because like it
does leap off and even cross over to a
certain degree with
um
uh uh uh Captain America the Winter
Soldier
but
it also kind of went some directions
later on that didn't feel like they were
taking the MCU into account so I think
there's actually some debate about how
Canon Agents of Shield is and and humans
was just such a big flop they were
ignoring it
um whereas uh there were more explicit
things like now that Daredevil has been
pulled into the MCU with Charlie Cox
even though
the like Kevin feige is being a little
squirrely about are the are the Netflix
series as we saw them are those Canon we
don't have a definitive answer yet but
we've had multiple characters pulled in
so far and so it just seemed like the
safer bet to put them there now granted
I didn't make the tier ranking I'm
trying to uh
just sort of think through what the
rationale would be
dead Deadpool s Deadpool 2B plus
um all right you know what I'll tell you
what they aren't on here but let's go
through real quick ages of Shield I only
did the first three seasons and then I
fell off it I'll put it in a b tier I
heard it got better later I can't
confirm that what I saw was uneven when
it was good it was very good but it
wasn't always good
in humans I only watched the premiere
it's a it's a d based on that alone
Deadpool the first one is an a
the second one is a c I actually really
don't like the second one very much at
all
um John vinyls coming in once more with
the Super Chat and that my friends is
why Thanos and Tony are such good photos
for each other and why Tony being the
one to take him down work so freaking
well I think they actually kind of
lucked out there because having Tony be
the one to take him down and sacrifice
himself to do so was probably a decision
largely influenced by uh he's leaving in
this is the character that started it
but it does happen to rhyme very well
thematically with those two I agree
um but yeah I could I okay I do need to
I do need to wrap it up because I'm
gonna get I'm gonna get sucked into the
chat and responding to all that thank
you everybody for joining me for this
this has been this has been fun I I like
doing this runaways also wasn't on the
list yeah I don't think that was ever
confirmed as Canon nor was
um
Cloak and Dagger
but like I've never seen either of those
so they would have been left off the
list for me anyway if they had been
there but thank you everybody for
joining me I hope you had fun I know I
did and I hope you have a great rest of
the weekend please remember that you are
beautiful you are valid you are loved
you're the council I am just running the
meetings until next time this council is
adjourned after
I have up other stuff that's going on so
on Monday new episode of jump gate on
the Council of Geeks podcast uh there
should be some more stuff on the break
room next week I am still playing on my
twitch stream uh Wednesdays and Fridays
I'm still playing Super lesbian animal
RPG which is great I highly recommend
that game
um and of course all the links on the
descriptions for like all this other
stuff other platforms Tick Tock
Instagram patreon pays the bills all
that like if you haven't already that
would be a big help uh how these things
perform after they have actually
um been alive thing is very inconsistent
but the likes do help so I'd certainly
appreciate those next week's Saturday
video is going to be heavy and I
I don't think I want to bring down the
mood of this stream by saying what it's
going to be but yeah it's it's gonna be
a lot
yeah John vinyl sneaking in with one
more at one point Nate Stevenson wrote
The Runaway series I did not realize
that huh I've never actually read The
Runaways oh cool
but anyway I think that's everything
that is coming up
uh
um Thursday next week should be a new
episode of cool and sword on Partridge
quill on Twitch that's the DND campaign
I'm a part of I get like there's links
down the description check those out
have a great rest of the weekend and uh
take care of yourselves
I'll see you
my cavity